bien
mes chers collègues je vous propose de
poursuivre notre matinée de travail
s'il vous plaît
nous entendons à présent monsieur
Christophe Rollin directeur général de
la caisse des retraites des personnels
de la RATP sur le projet de loi de
financement rectificatif de la sécurité
sociale pour 2023 j'indique que cette
audition fait l'objet d'une captation
vidéo retransmise en direct sur le site
du Sénat l'objectif de cette audition et
de présenter les impacts du projet de
loi sur la caisse de la RATP monsieur
Rollin je vais vous laisser la parole
pour un propos introductif avant que
nous rapporteurs Elisabeth Doisneau
rapporteur général René Paul Savary
rapporteur pour les retraites et Sylvie
dermeyer rapporteur pour avis de la
commission des finances puis les
commissaires ne vous adressent leurs
questions
bonjour à toutes bonjour à tous
bah écoutez je vais être cours en propos
liminaire puisque je crois que vous avez
un petit peu de retard alors je suis
Christophe Rollin directeur de la crp
ratp vous recevez il y a quelques
minutes monsieur Villard directeur la
CNAV pour donner un ordre de grandeur je
crois que c'est plusieurs milliers
plusieurs dizaines de milliers de
salariés côté cnaval et Acer ATP tenant
une qui a 20 ans d'âge qui est tout
récent
qui composait de 40 personnes donc vous
avez à peu près quand même l'ordre de
grandeur qui fait que ça reste malgré
tout un organisme efficient il faut
aussi savoir le dire nous sommes 40 pour
gérer le régime de retraite la RATP donc
c'est un organisme créé en 2006 qui est
indépendant je le précise puisque je
crois que Monsieur agülo on n'est pas là
aujourd'hui qui est complètement
indépendante RATP enfin complètement
indépendant
qui est qui est sous la tutelle des
ministères notamment du budget des
affaires sociales mais qui est
indépendant jusqu'en en 2006 qui a 15
ans
les retraites étaient gérées par
l'entreprise elle-même par un service
des pensions ce n'est plus le cas comme
vous savez depuis depuis 2006 donc notre
caisse notre petite caisse est
indépendante donc en gros pour vous
donner quelques d'or quelques ordres
d'idées donc 40 personnes on verse un
peu plus d'un milliard deux de
prestations
en croissance régulière chaque année je
crois qu'on aura l'occasion d'en parler
à peu près 52 000 pensionnés et peupro
42000 salariés sous statut je précise ce
statut régime spécial
voilà je
suis prêt à répondre à vos
interrogations sur
l'ordre madame douanour rapporteur
général puis monsieur René Paul Savary
puis madame fermier
merci Monsieur de nous laisser le loisir
d'attaquer par les questions directement
c'est peut-être aussi bien mais on va
peut-être
redonner les bases donc mes questions
seront très très simples en fait la
première étant quelles sont les
spécificités du régime
pour le personnel de la RATP par rapport
aux autres régimes comme ça ça nous
donnera une perspective
pour tous les autres régimes
obligatoires de base j'entends ma
deuxième question c'est quelle sera donc
l'incident j'ai posé la même question
tout à l'heure
la précédente personne qui était
auditionnée
l'incidence de la fermeture des du
régime aux nouveaux entrants sur sa
trajectoire financière aussi c'est
intéressant de voir comment ça a des
répercussions budgétaires à quelle
échéance son extinction devrait-elle
intervenir
ma troisième question le versement par
le régime général d'une compensation de
la perte de la cotisation induite par la
fermeture du régime aux nouveaux
entrants est-il envisagé merci
alors si je les prends dans l'ordre
quels sont les spécificités du régime
RATP on pourrait dans un premier temps
dire que c'était un régime qui est assez
proche de celui de la fonction publique
je dirais que c'est celui auquel il
ressemble plus il a malgré tout
certaines spécificités qu'il rattachent
au régime général après moi je dirais
qu'il a il a quand même une spécificité
si on si on met en comparaison c'est que
c'est finalement le régime qui distingue
le mieux ce qui relève du service
sédentaire et du service actif
finalement dans ce régime vous avez 90%
du personnel c'est assez atypique qui
est en actif en catégorie actif c'est à
dire qu'il relève un tableau soit soit B
et qu'est-ce que ça veut dire une
catégorie active à la ATP et ça rejoint
un débat que vous avez dans le cas du du
présent projet de loi
si finalement c'est des personnes dont
on a considérés quels exercés dans le
métier présenter une certaine pénibilité
alors plus ou moins importante
assez importante quand vous êtes en
tableau B un peu moins importantes qu'on
attend en tableaux et finalement
aujourd'hui cette pénibilité elle est
pris en compte dans le régime depuis
très longtemps puis depuis
en tout cas 1945 c'est-à-dire secrétaire
là existe il est plaignant parce qu'ils
couvre 90% du personnel ce qui n'est pas
rien et derrière il y a tout un certain
nombre de mécanismes qui ont été mis en
place et qui existent depuis longtemps
finalement qui sont qui sont pas qui
sont pas nouveaux qui permettent à ces
personnes donc qui exercent des métiers
pénibles recenser essentiellement dans
deux tableaux mais quand on en détail
ces tableaux sont subdivisés pardon en
d'autres tableaux qui permet qui leur
permet pardon de bénéficier
droit en termes de retraite
d'abaissement d'âge de majoration du
réseau qui sont finalement à du
proportion
du caractère plus ou moins pénible de
leur métier
et c'est fait de manière assez fine
finalement ce qui est indépendamment des
deux catégories vous avez la même chose
la SNCF mais SNCF vous avez deux
catégories et en gros le personnel dans
une catégorie il en change pas elle est
RATP vous avez deux catégories qui se
subtilisent encore en une quinzaine
catégorie le personnel change dès que je
peux changer dans la semaine il peut
changer même dans le mois et associer à
cette catégorie BCD vous avez un
pourcentage
qui leur attache soit au tableau bas
soit au tableau B donc je rappelle B
c'est les plus pénibles c'est
essentiellement les conducteurs les
conducteurs de bus vous dever B c'est
plutôt la maintenance donc vous avez un
pourcentage qui le rattache soit au à
soit ob et qui derrière décline un
certain nombre de droits afférentes à
cette période et à cette proportion le
droit donc abaissement de l'âge de
départ en retraite majoration la durée
des séries donc finalement si je résume
la pénibilité existe dans ce régime elle
est finalement bien pris en compte après
on parlera de des conséquences
financières bien sûr mais elle est pris
en compte de manière finalement assez
assez pertinente avec des droits
associés et le deuxième critère la
deuxième différence moi je fais pour ce
régime c'est si je compare aux autres en
tout cas dans la mesure où je peux les
connaître
donc premier critère cette prise en
compte de la pérennité qui finalement
assez fine deuxième spécificité c'est
je dirais une assez forte
individualisation des droits
c'est-à-dire que
par exemple le critère générationnel
marche très mal dans ce régime
il y a une assez fortunisation des
droits parce que chaque salarié en
fonction de son appartement à telle ou
telle tableau en fonction du moment où
il sera dans tel ou tel tableau il peut
très facilement
prévoir et individualiser sa pension de
retraite alors indépendamment du fait
que comme vous savez on prend son
dernier salaire en tout cas des six
derniers mois etc ce qui est quand même
plus facile pour calculer sa façon de
retraite corriger générale mais il y a
une très forte individualisation par
chaque salarié de ce qu'il veut faire la
retraite de combien il veut toucher de à
quel moment ils veulent faire et à ce
titre on a notamment développé un
simulateur qui est très très fin qui est
finalement un outil de préliquidation
contrairement à beaucoup de simulateurs
mais finalement ça peut aussi être vécu
comme un avantage c'est à dire dans le
cas d'un régime pas répartition je
rappelle on est on reste en tout cas ce
régime d'un régime par répartition
malgré tout chaque salarié de la RTP qui
est aujourd'hui au statut à une très
forte possibilité je dirais de définir
le moment le montant et les conditions
de son départ en retraite voilà
pour répondre à votre première question
sinon on retrouve des choses qui sont
très similaires en termes de droit à la
fonction publique en termes de calcul de
taux de d'âge etc etc mais je voulais
insister sur ces deux points parce que
je crois qu'ils sont ils sont
d'actualité
vous vouliez
une autre question oui on va peut-être
poursuivre tes terminer est-ce que vous
avez répondu
à la deuxième alors Monsieur Savary s'il
vous plaît la deuxième non non il y a la
deuxième la troisième
[Musique]
le chiffre qui est donné de la Randon
dans l'étude impact et je valide grosso
modo 1500 à 2000 embauches c'est entre
20 et 25 millions de cotisations
retraite donc si demain à partir du 1er
septembre du 23 en année pleine c'est
1500 ou 2000 selon les cas au salaire
d'embauche qui sont ceux actuel ne se
font plus
dans le cas du régime de retraite RS
mais au régime général c'est chaque
année 20 à 25 millions de cotisations en
moins qui seront perçus et bien sûr en
cumulé
je je rappelle juste le l'état de crpe
la caisse de retraite verse un peu moins
d'amir3 de prestations dont 780 en tout
cas en 2002 financé par la subvention en
état donc vous avez un ordre d'idée 20
millions de cotisations en moins 20 à 25
la première année et en cumulé bien sûr
les années les années suivantes
sur la troisième élément je n'ai pas
d'éléments autre que ce que le
gouvernement a donné c'est qui
c'est-à-dire à la fois la garantie d'une
compassion de la perte de cotisation
après les modalités restent à définir je
crois dans le cas des lois de finances
et de financement de la Sécu pour 2024
soit par le biais d'une simulation du
majoration pardon de la subvention de
l'État parce que déjà aujourd'hui il y a
une subvention de l'État qui est
conséquente qui est même majoritaire
dans le financement du régime je le
rappelle
soit voilà soit dans le cadre d'un
transfert des régimes on va dire
récipient d'air des cotisations de masse
des régimes général et
suivre ah oui vous aviez une à quelle
échéance on extension devrait-elle
intervenir
je peux pas vous répondre en tout cas je
peux vous faire la réponse que que
d'autres vous ferez c'est-à-dire
qu'aujourd'hui même plus que ça fait
juste pour donner notre idée aujourd'hui
j'ai encore une personne de personne
personne qui a bénéficié la pension dans
la version en 1947 vous voyez qu'on peut
l'avoir très tôt dans ce régime et pas
de conditions d'âge donc j'ai une veuve
qui a eu qui perçoit sa pension
inversion depuis 47 et un retraité qui
perçoit une pension en dite de réforme
depuis 1952 vous voyez 40 ans c'est un
peu court je dirais même c'est 80 ans
c'est 80 ans quand on regarde
voilà il y aura encore quelques
retraités dans 4 exactement
concernant
l'extension du dispositif de retraite
anticipée est-ce que est-ce qu'il y a
des modalités qui s'appliquent à votre
régime puisque la plupart du temps c'est
pour des salariés des régimes généraux
mais est-ce que ça s'applique à votre
régime
et combien d'assurés exerce actuellement
en cumul emploi retraite
alors pour répondre à votre question
parce que ça varie aujourd'hui
disponible de retraite anticipée
c'est-à-dire de carrière longue on est
d'accord c'est carrière longue parce que
on a des salariés à la LP comme vous
savez qui peuvent partir à 52 à 57 ans
voire même avant pour des titulaires de
pension de réforme ou pour des maires de
famille de 3 enfants et plus mais par
rapport du carré long il s'applique mais
il y a très très peu de personnes il y
en a j'ai fait le recensement il y en a
aujourd'hui 152 donc c'est un dispositif
qui est peu utilisé dans le régime ce
qui peut s'expliquer parce que les gens
ont la possibilité de partir plus tôt
sur le cumulant plan retraite alors
grosso modo jusqu'à l'année dernière on
avait à peu près
à 52 vont partir à 54 sur 57 vont partir
à 59 quand même oui mais quand vous
regardez aujourd'hui la réalité ce 52
par exemple c'est le tableau des les
plus actifs ils partent pas à 52 dans
les faits ils partent à plus de 56 ans
aujourd'hui et grosso modo chaque année
l'âge de départ prend un quand vous
regardez année à parler c'est 3 à 4
voilà 3 à 4 mois donc aujourd'hui il
part à plus de 56 ans les les a partent
à 57 ans et demi
donc vous voyez bien qu'il ne part pas à
dès qu'ils ont leur date d'ouverture de
rois
ils partent en général à peu près 85 %
des salariés RATP aujourd'hui par contre
il n'a pas de décote c'est à dire dès
lors qu'il n'a plus de décote c'est pas
pas j'ai des gens j'ai des salariés qui
ont des droits ouverts
je pense que non aujourd'hui dans la
réalité des faits surtout que la réforme
Touraine n'a pas encore fini ses effets
il faut quand même le rappeler
pour pour notre régime en tout cas c'est
c'est encore le cas aujourd'hui si vous
prenez les catégories B qui partent à
plus de 56 ans Léa qui sont à 57 et demi
si vous voyez que chaque année
l'âge de départ moyen prend 3 à 4 mois
il n'y a pas un impact énorme en tout
cas je pense pas qu'il y a un impact sur
les gestes de départ en trade il pourra
y avoir un impact sur les montants de
pension parce qu'effectivement demain
pour calculer le taux au lieu de prendre
aujourd'hui 168 trimestres parce qu'il a
monté en charge on prendra 172
trimestres donc il pourrait y avoir un
ratio un peu plus pénalisant mais en
termes d'âge de départ en traite
je pense pas très honnêtement que le
fait de passer de 52 à 54 ou de
57 à 59 pour Leah et les B
et un impact et un impact considérable
et sur donc
le cumul emploi retraite il y en a
beaucoup qui le prennent après sur les
clients
jusqu'à présent il y avait chaque année
à peu près 500 à 600 personnes et l'an
dernier on est passé à 1477 oui
ça peut s'expliquer je pense
je veux pas parler à place de
l'entreprise mais pour deux raisons
d'abord on a quand même de plus en plus
des gens
qui ne partent pas au taux maximum
c'est-à-dire qui ne font pas liquider
leur pension sur la base de 75% pour pas
oublier ça la moyenne c'est plutôt 65%
d'ailleurs le chiffre quelques la
pension 75 la réalité c'est plutôt 65 il
faut avoir ça en tête donc qui partent
avec une pension
en tout cas qui n'est pas forcément au
plat donc derrière il part trop
relativement tôt quand même 56 57 58 ans
en moyenne la moyenne c'est 57 ans et 3
mois c'est quand même assez tôt si on
compare au régime général donc ils
reprennent une activité assez facilement
ils reprennent une activité assez
facilement
et aujourd'hui je crois ils peuvent
aussi en reprendre une dans l'entreprise
en étant embauché sous statut régime
général c'est à dire qu'ils font
liquider leur pension ça tu RS peut-être
un peu moins que ce qu'elle aurait pu
être mais ils reprennent une activité
voir la même activité sous saturé
pour vous donner un ordre d'idée je
pense que vous avez le chiffre
aujourd'hui
au sein du régime RATP vous avez plus de
5000 personnes qui sont qui relèvent du
régénéral qui sont contractuels et c'est
même à peu près je parle en l'absence du
DRH de la RATP mais c'est un tiers des
recrutements annuels aujourd'hui
merci Madame vermillier s'il vous plaît
merci madame la Présidente
je suis directeur j'ai trois questions
qui sont liées vous avez pas encore
abordé le la question de l'ouverture à
la concurrence et comment elle se mêle à
cette réforme
[Musique]
sous cet aspect là
je vais vous poser une question
classique
j'imagine qu'avec la réforme on a dû
vous demander davantage d'estimation sur
le coup du déséquilibre démographique et
le coût des droits spécifiques il n'y a
pas de T2 à la RATP comme il y en a un à
la SNCF mais du coup est-ce que vous
avez des précisions sur le coup de
déséquilibre démographique et celui des
droits spécifiques
on vient à l'instant d'entendre le
directeur de la CNAV
qui a pas l'air d'envisager qui puisse y
avoir une compensation de la CNAV avec
la fermeture du régime RATP alors vous
venez de nous dire que
il y a une perte
estimée de 20 à 25 millions par an
chaque année voilà chaque année avec la
fermeture du régime
est-ce que comment vous vous imaginez le
devenir de
la crp ratp dans ces conditions puisque
non seulement
il y aura de moins en moins de cotisants
en tout cas il y en aura plus de nouveau
et puis il y aura toujours les
prestations à continuer à honorer
donc voilà et ce que vous vous imaginiez
une compensation CNAV pour ces
nouveaux pour ces salariés qui et qui
cotiseront plus
RATP
et puis voilà le devenir de la caisse
elle-même merci
alors si j'essaie de reprendre dans
l'ordre vos questions l'ouverture à la
concurrence c'était un gros sujet
pour moi au moins aussi important que
que celui qui nous
occupe aujourd'hui
comme vous le savez la loi l'homme a
prévu l'ouverture la concurrence
alors dans le cas du ferroviaire ça a
été traité s'agissant des RATP
aujourd'hui ça n'a pas encore été traité
parce que les décrets d'application et
tout tient dans le décret d'applications
n'ont pas été pris encore comme vous le
savez la loi m'a prévu que cette
ouverture est concurrence interviendra
dès le 1er janvier 2025 il y a déjà des
marchés aujourd'hui
les décrets aujourd'hui ne sont pas pris
je crois que c'est ils sont repoussés un
peu plus tard en même temps c'est majeur
ce que ça veut dire concrètement et
c'est un peu l'exercice intellectuel
qu'il faut qu'il faut qu'on arrive à
faire c'est qu'aujourd'hui
on parlait de Claude compère dans ce qui
reste les 42000 à peu près 43000
salariés qui restent il y en a peu ou 19
à 20 000 qui vous promets j'avais 2025
bon quitter les entreprises c'est à dire
plus de 40%. ils vont quitter
l'entreprise ils vont aller soit dans
les filiales de la RATP soit dans des
organismes qui ont remporté les marchés
mais il perdons le statut il perdant le
statut c'est finalement c'est l'inverse
de ce qu'on fait sur la réforme ou en
gros les nouveaux embauchés vont garder
tout leur statut quand on regarde sauf
les droits de retraite mais là c'est
l'inverse ces gens-là ils vont quitter
l'entreprise ils vont perdre leur statut
ils vont la loi prévoit qu'il garde une
chose c'est leur droit à retraite au gym
spécial avec toutes ces spécificités
ce qui n'est pas simple parce que ça
veut dire que demain la crp ratp va
devoir gérer 20 000 personnes auproux
dans X entreprise 10 20 100 ou
employeurs
relevant du privé tu réjou général donc
avec un fonctionnement privé des
cotisations de droit commun la DSN etc
et en même temps
garantir si je me fais la loi en tout
cas qui qui tire en deux trois lignes
les mêmes droits que si ces personnes
étaient restées dans le régime ce qui
est pas facile parce que la plupart de
ces droits sont construits
enfin sont construit son associés à la
structure à la mode de fonctionnement
des RATP ne serait-ce que les emplois
etc donc c'est un sacré enjeu technique
financier aussi je ferai le lien avec
votre deuxième question c'est comment
demain récupérer les cotisations gérer
des droits pour des personnes qui
n'appartiendront plus à la RATP avec
lesquels on aura pas les relations qu'on
a aujourd'hui et en même temps pour
lesquelles il va falloir inventer des
choses je vous parlais des tableaux des
tableaux B c'est 90% du quotidien RATP
ça n'existe pas ça dans le privé et
comment on va faire voilà comment on va
créer ces critères de
voilà donc je pense que le sujet
ouverture la concurrence est plus
complexe sur le sujet réforme d'un
certain côté
alors le coût du déséquilibre moi je ne
peux pas parler à la place de du
gouvernement ni de Monsieur Villard il
est bien évident que à partir du 1er
septembre 2023
le fait de de ne plus percevoir les
cotisations des nouveaux embaucher va
fortement dégrader les conduire je donne
juste un ordre d'idée alors aujourd'hui
nous a pas été demandé de les financer
aujourd'hui de les évaluer aujourd'hui
pour répondre à notre question il nous a
été demandé de continuer à fonctionner à
l'existence c'est-à-dire les prévisions
là qu'on est en train de faire notamment
pour les le congénieurs de l'État se
font sur les bases existantes mais quand
vous regardez aujourd'hui 2022 en tout
cas l'année dernière la substance en
détail qui a été requise pour équilibrer
le régime était d'un peu plus de 780
millions
500 millions de cotisations et 79
millions de subventions dans quatre ans
c'est-à-dire dans quatre ans 2026
selon les estimations qui ont été faites
en septembre donc ils devront être
majorés pour tenir compte de l'impact
des revalorisations
des pensions mais aussi de la valeur du
point RATP qui qui ont eu lieu le
dernier dans 4 ans 2026
a un régime constant c'est à dire sans
perdre des cotisations le besoin de
financement est estimé à 960 millions
donc vous voyez c'est 180 même 190
millions de plus
si à partir du 1er septembre 2023 on ne
reçoit pas les cotisations c'est à dire
20 à 25 millions chaque année qui se
cumulent
vous voyez bien que ce besoin de
financement dans quatre ans il sera pas
de de 960 millions il sera d'un milliard
deux parce que voilà donc l'état s'est
engagé en tout cas voilà je crois que
c'est c'est un discours constant qu'il a
eu à compenser selon des modalités qui
restent effectivement à définir dans le
cas des lois de finances des lois
financières on va dire de fin d'année
que ce soit une majoration de la
subvention actuelle pourquoi pas
que ce soit un reversement de la CNAV ou
la cause
c'est pas complètement impossible parce
que je vous disais tout à l'heure si je
prends l'ouverture de la concurrence à
partir du 1er janvier 2025 c'est 20000
personnes qui vont à les régimes général
ils vont cotiser à Lacosse au régime
général mais en même temps pour sauver
des droits au reste donc il faudra bien
en toute logique que s'il y a des droits
au RS il y a un reversement
tout ou partie je sais pas des
cotisations qui ont été payées par ces
personnes là
mais voilà ça aujourd'hui je ne sais pas
quel sera le choix du gouvernement sur
le sujet
non pour répondre à votre question sur
les droits spécifiques c'est une bonne
question non il y a j'ai pas eu de
demandes ça c'est un sujet très
compliqué avec la Cour des comptes a
essayé d'aborder il y a quelques années
si vous rappelez et qui avait un peu
conclu à la difficulté non c'est
aujourd'hui il n'y a pas de réel
estimation il y a des choses partielles
mais vous avez raison il n'y a pas de
réel estimation de ce qui fait la
spécificité de ce régime et comme vous
l'avez forte très bien souligné il n'y a
pas de T2 aujourd'hui donc je n'ai pas
de de chiffres aujourd'hui sérieux à
vous avancer
pour le devenir de la crp ratp
alors je sais pas si la SERP RATP sera
encore là dans 80 ans pour gérer les
derniers retraités nous sommes un tout
petit régime
après je dirais et je conclurai là
dessus juste deux choses
[Musique]
c'est important aussi d'avoir ça en
ligne de mire quand on gère
c'est un organisme qui aujourd'hui est
très efficient c'est coup de gestion
sont à peu près de 0,4%
la comparaison avec beaucoup
d'organismes je pense qu'on est plutôt à
3 à 4% du coût de gestion nous sommes à
0,4% de coût de gestion donc
faisons parfois attention on peut être
un petit régime et très efficient
04%, je pense c'est difficile de faire
mieux et en terme de qualité de service
je crois que c'est aussi important on
crée pas un régime pour créer un régime
on crée pour rendre le service le plus
satisfaisant possible
au coup le moins élevé possible donc le
coup je l'ai évoqué en terme de service
aujourd'hui quand je regarde tous nos
indicateurs quand je regarde les
résultats des enquêtes cette section ils
sont très bons très positifs plus de 95%
de satisfait on liquide 100% dépensions
dans les délais depuis 6 ans que je suis
là n'a jamais eu de solde et nous
répondons en autodé téléphone par
exemple et tout entre 97 et 99%. tout ça
pour dire je ne sais pas jusque quand
vivra la CRP ATP mais
je souligne juste que
qu'aujourd'hui elle gère bien ses
retraités et à moindre coût et que et
que si demain notre organisme devra le
faire à sa place je pense qu'il serait
faudra avoir en ligne de mire
ces éléments à la fois en termes de
services rendus et de coût de gestion
parce que c'est aussi important
je sais pas si je répondais toutes les
questions
merci est-ce qu'il y a d'autres
non j'ai pas d'inscrit non merci
beaucoup Monsieur le Directeur